one of your functions over time has been
to communicate scientific knowledge to
the public yeah and that's why I was
quite surprised to hear you talk about
the idea that we all exist on a spectrum
where you wake up one day and you feel
like you're more female and more male
xxxy chromosomes are insufficient
because when we wake up in the morning
we exaggerate whatever feature we want
to portray the gender of our choice
suppose no matter my chromosomes today I
feel eighty percent female 20 male I'm
gonna I'm gonna put on makeup I'm gonna
do this tomorrow I might feel 80 percent
male I'll remove the makeup and I'll
wear a muscle shirt
why do you care yeah what what what
business it is it of yours to require
that I fulfill
your inability to think of gender on a
spectrum my only point
was that if who you decide is male and
female
in the street
is a construct of of of style
and Trends
and what the beauty industrial complex
wants you to see
if that's how we establish gender
then maybe some people want to be fluid
within that gender
identify so they'll they'll wear a skirt
but maybe have a beard or they'll mix
and match that in whatever way sorry I'm
not wait wait I'm almost done I'm almost
done
so okay if a person using the tools of
the beauty industrial complex wants to
mix and match this yeah and they are
expressing
their freedom
in a free country to do so
um
why is your job to tell them not to okay
that's my only point and so I'm speaking
of gender expression and the freedom to
do so and
if you want to restrict that
so first of all I don't know a single
person and I've talked we've talked to
trans people on the show we have trans
employees at trigonometry uh we we've
spoken to all sorts of people about this
issue I do not know a single person who
wants to prevent people from dressing
how they want or behaving how they want
or choosing any name that they want
however so you don't but you know such
people are out there I'm sure such
people exist in the same way that there
are people who believe that the Earth is
flat and so on but they're a tiny
minority they exist I don't know how
tiny they are objects fair point however
what I would say is that the
conversation in the public Consciousness
has become prominent not between people
who want to defend the right of anyone
to dress how they want and the people
who want to prevent that the reason the
conversations become an issue is that we
assign and allow certain privileges to
People based on their sex if you are
female you get to go to places the only
other females are in like changing rooms
and toilets and so on if you are female
you get to compete only with people of
your sex because females are at a
disadvantage in physical competition to
males in almost every sport in other
words we carve out certain areas where
your sex matters tremendously even
though we May respect your right
everywhere else to believe that you are
whatever you are to dress however you
are Etc so your claim that today you
woke up and put lipstick on and grew
your hair out long and tweezed out your
mustache and whatever and therefore you
are female has an impact on other people
in certain contexts in which that is a
problem only two contexts do you have
others sorry I wasn't finished and in in
in in in in those contexts it is
essential people would argue to protect
women from unfair competition and from
various risks for which female only
spaces already exist that's why people
are having this conversation it's not
out of bigger do you have more than
those two examples and I'll address each
of those in turn but you have more than
those two
probably not okay so so let me address
those two examples directly I'll address
it Sports is very important I I you said
that I remembered so
um so but
you don't seem to have a third example
so and even if you do we presume that
would be a very distant third compared
to those two cases no there's a third
one I can give you very easily in this
country for politics we have female only
shortlists for uh positions in in
Parliament uh therefore that's
interesting okay well that's another
example I can give you more so uh female
only short lists there are certain
targets within corporations for uh
diversity targets to have a certain
number of women on the board therefore
when you make a claim that you are
female you are attempting whether
intentionally or not to insert yourself
into categories that are deliberately
designed to protect women's interests
that is the concern that people have so
there's four examples for you there
please sure so interesting about the
parliament I have to look into that to
find out what the is it is it try to
ensure the representation of women is
that the goal yeah okay perfectly noble
cause there so
um about uh personal changing spaces
okay
um
that's a solvable problem of course and
we basically have accomplished that here
in Manhattan where I live uh practically
all bathrooms are either
uh multi-gender or or solo bathrooms so
only one person at a time or you walk
into a space and there's stalls that are
closed off but then you exit the stall
and you come to a communal sink okay so
it's a solvable problem where everyone
has a private space rather than for
themselves rather than having a gender
private space okay that's it's solvable
it's on a level by the way let me give
an example uh we have a school from the
early 20th century in New York and it's
and I just saw it the other day there's
an entrance here and an entrance there
and this entrance says girls and this
entrance says boys it's like what the
[__] what what what you step operate
them just to enter the school I can look
back on that and say that was ridiculous
you guys what were you thinking but back
then I'm sure it made complete sense
that you're going to send the girls to
that entrance and there's an elementary
school and the boys through that
entrance okay so it is possible to look
back on whatever you were doing and say
my gosh that was really short-sighted
and look at the solution that was
proposed and implemented that was a good
idea we moved on from that okay so I
remember boys rooms where you come out
and you know you whip it out and we'd
all be peeing into a trough okay we
don't have those anymore
because we're technologically very far
behind yeah okay so it's it's a and then
we had urinals just lined up on a wall
that was a little more private and now
those urinals have little small but real
dividers so you're not like looking over
so so there are solution to the Privacy
problem and we've all but solved that
here I can't speak for every state in
the United States definitely here in New
York City the bathrooms it's not all
right it's that second with sports very
interesting
um there was a case where a woman wanted
to be disqualified they wanted to
disqualify her from an event
and she had very big muscles and she had
naturally high testosterone levels okay
and she was genetically
female but uh unusually high
um testosterone levels and so that
weirded everybody out so I'm wondering
whether the future of those Sports
is you don't contest gender
with gender you can test hormone ratios
well hold on a second what the
difference is phys the difference is
physiologically between men and women
are not just hormonal women have a
different hip angle they have different
heart capacity they have different lung
capacity I mean there are profound
physiological differences different bone
density we've had okay to talk about it
I don't have a problem with that then
you find ways to slice the population so
that whatever the event is
is
is interestingly contested so for
example I wrestled in my life I was
Captain of my high school wrestling team
it would be unfair
for me at 190 pounds which is what I was
back then to wrestle someone 120 pounds
hold on it would actually be unfair for
you to wrestle someone who is also 190
pounds but let me let me work my way
there let me just work my way there
because you're fine you're you're you
are I respect the how active your brain
is but I've thought about all this and
just allow me to speak it at the rate
that I do okay so so
um it would be unfair so they have us in
wrestling they said let's make weight
categories okay so we make weight
categories so I don't wrestle the 120 I
wrestle 190 pounder so a wrestling match
is not just this one person against the
other person it's ten matches and each
one is intensely interesting because
they are matched
okay
so
what the trans
conversation
is foisting upon us
is the need to find ways to slice the
athletic universe
such that we still have
interesting Fair matches and is it a
combination of did you go through
puberty
um uh as a male and then transition did
you have puberty blockers
um what is your hormone level now uh as
you if you want to compete so it
requires more creative thought rather
than saying no to it all let's be
creative about this as we were with
wrestling as we were as we are with
practically any other sport in rowing
there's a heavyweight rowing and there's
light weight growing they don't compete
against each other somebody came up with
that to resolve the problem because more
than one category of person wanted to
compete so I agree with you it's an
unsolved problem yes but it's not
unsolvable given what we know about
human physiology so why not rise to that
occasion and solve it rather than take
your older view of the world and worse
modern emergent conduct of people to fit
that
okay well can we just come back to the
female shortlist and other opportunities
that women are afforded by virtue of
being women and them now being excluded
from that because males are entering
that competition yeah so another a
deeper problem thank you for bringing
that up a deeper problem there is
um why were women underrepresented to
begin with what kind of bias exists
within Parliament or among the voters
maybe even the female voters that
prevented the representation from being
there in the first place that that's a
whole other social question that maybe
can and should be answered at a deeper
level than a quota coming in after the
fact oh I'm not a fan of quotas but I
would address that question
hold on a second that's not addressing
the question at all the question is
female shortlist exists should
biological males be allowed to enter
those female shortlists that's that's as
simple as the question is
yeah I'm saying you I would ask why you
have the short list in the first place
it's because there's something
there's something deeper that's wrong
with society that women are
underrepresented in governance so to to
so to say now
to protect that now and not try to get
to the root of that problem I think is
the cart in front of the horse so so I
would go deeper to that problem
there's opportunities are being
curtailed today
because they are being forced to compete
whether in sports or elsewhere against
people who have some kind of advantage
of win a transitional period so we have
to figure that out
but the the way to figure out things
that requires solutions to Progressive
change is not to regress it to how
things once were if that were the case I
would still be drinking from a
segregated water fountain okay oh let's
merge the water fountains and let's
let's create the opportunities from
below so that we don't even need the
short list okay that's how I would
approach this so yeah we're in the
middle of solving that problem now
figure let's figure it out together
I I think a lot of people would have an
issue with what you're saying Neil is
because they see women being denied
opportunities they see an unfair playing
field metaphorically and literally
speaking so fix the playing field dammit
what don't don't say it's an unclear
playing field so all of a sudden the big
issue is trans women taking the slot of
a woman in an unfair playing field fix
the playing field and you know something
the day you fix that playing field this
conversation will look completely
ridiculous
that's what I'm trying to tell you
foreign